you're welcome to this video playing
with Jesus from Finland and I'm playing
the Kings gambit I'm still um I still
have a very good score with that Knight
f7 Knight f6 is not a move that I really
know I mean I know that it is existent
but I don't know them
the real ideas hmm maybe just just take
him ah okay okay now I remember this is
a game of fishes check Queen edge 4chan
f to check so this is a very very solid
way of meeting the Kings gambit for
black just aiming for an yeah sort of
queenless middle game or endgame even
with them white having no get extra
center part but other than that it's
it's very equal ish okay he attacks the
spot which is really a nuisance
yeah okay I cannot cover that I mean not
really but if it takes I take on d6 play
Bishop f4 this is a very good Czech
development will be hard for him to keep
the porn
probably needs to cancel him
yeah castles probably good okay he
didn't cancel but I can play d5 now all
right
this was the idea
I thought this is dangerous really
oopsie seven and so on let's enter on
the seventh
yeah the the sis's is not easy to play
for black okay taking and D six assists
this is to direct probably yeah probably
it is I still wonder how to learn how to
play
yeah but I think I need to play in a
direct way here I cannot I didn't see
anything anything else really
then this direct approach Bishop c4 rook
t1 in this kind of stuff I should have
given the check first and just check
first of course this was foolish I mean
okay look at this this is still pretty
pretty good good game for white but of
course I must give the check first
terrible ok blackest black has got big
problems anyway but it was much much
stronger with the check first okay now
take on a6 he has some ship f4
hmm
yeah that's that's not good
Rock tea - hmm submit lame
don't know I don't really know how to
continue there's a default for this
looks lose this looks wrong somehow
yeah rookies seven captain Taggart yeah
okay need to need to handle literally to
need to play that what what can you do
it's the good problem
what's black supposed to do I don't
really see how we entangles himself
it's um difficult yeah
droopy ate probably just trying to
somehow untangle okay d7 is probably not
so great okay I just I just pushed the
king
yeah the activity it's it's enormous
king f7 died just go King a5 King e6 I
think this is probably winning I think
he needs to go g6 IAM which is not
exactly what you like to play but maybe
you need to
Wow you can afford that
hmm
kingi v v6
yeah yeah it's quite active
but how do actually win now this is not
not so clear at least I I don't see it
at the moment I just take it
Jackie I think this is this is actually
winning
King King King takes King e6 is an easy
one because I dominate the rook and rook
takes I think rook c8 should also win
yeah okay rook takes rook c8 also wins I
threatened to take and Queen he needs to
go look the idea I think I can just take
it and grab here with the winning end
game I just get the h-bomb okay time
warning
check check you have the beep on this
chassis wooden check check check check
on playing this really idiotic check
check check check check check him game
good sausage oh wow what the heck did I
do I was at what time here check that
was check the falling asleep check is
really easy with the beep phone yeah but
I need to go with the king here
check check check check the other thing
is there are no state matrix check
so just King here check and then try and
be three of course yeah I mean
afterwards it's it's always very easy I
just was completely retained at you I
don't know why this is still a two to
play and then then move the king you
always get this kind of and then then
the king it wants us I don't know
fell asleep here at the board other than
that it was it was a pretty good game I
mean I don't know not good but
interesting of course the the big issue
here Bishop c4 was just awful
rookie 7 just just wins it straight away
yeah now not that just here
and he's busted him no no way to told
that this is simply terrible it's quite
the same just he hasn't canceled and
this is not the same and okay this one
is so much so terrible he just get
doesn't get the opponent I have a big
initiative it's not a doubt him never
born last year but the pond down to yeah
the way it went it was also good but not
so convincing d7 it was also an
interesting idea
I overlooked something here the computer
says I can take I thought I could good
sacrifice here check it's a check oh
it's a check it's a check on f7 ah if he
booth overlooked that this is cool I
look at it we both overlooked that cook
up to 6 Bishop f7 rook F same shake of
course I thought Bishop takes rook takes
I didn't see that it was a check and
then I can just give the check on c8 and
then get the rook on d6 with who the
winning end game but it's a check oh wow
so he could have just taken on d6 yeah
and after that we get this end game
which is probably very good for what and
maybe maybe even winning yeah it was it
was okay now what I did but check also
this is this is really winning but of
course it was fairly funniest
but not to win against the poem check I
mean time-wise I was just just too slow
I don't know what I did here I'm about
three seconds up okay so I'm game with
many many mistakes and this is a typical
thing that you're at least that happens
to me quite often but that you overlook
that this reason you should have said
look I said is a check this is funny all
right
thanks for watching